bonjour là mais sinimalé qu'ils agissent
aujourd'hui ça explique azote comment
faire une famille peut semer un type de
plantes et aux petits de légumes aussi
donc on peut avoir un gros rendement par
rapport à ça aujourd'hui
moi je vais semer de la reine marguerite
ce qu'ils adhéraient sachets c'est
vraiment spécifique à au climat
métropole donc ici comme un ouf on a un
climat tropical donc on peut semer toute
l'année je veux présenter le matériel
nécessaire pour faire la place mii donc
une terrine un vitrage un bouton brière
qui a plusieurs types dont brillent un
donc pas très haut pas rétabli impôts de
13 une baguette pour l'extraction des
plans après la ceni un tasseau que j'ai
fabriqué moi même des étiquettes pour
marquer le nom et la date de la semis de
la tourbe traditionnelle qu'on trouve en
pépinière ou dans les magasins de deux
jardins et du terreau de semis
on trouve aussi dans les magasins de
jardin ne pas prendre de la terre normal
parce que la terre contient beaucoup de
bactéries la terreur a tendance à se
damner donc pas d'aération pour les
graines donc il y aura un mauvais dès
maintenant des grains en fait donc voilà
mauvais germination en fait
avant de faire là la famille donc le
petit conseil c'est de bien d affecter
la terrine et le vitrage donc afin que
qu'il y aura pas de bactéries nid de
maladies qu'ils puissent attaquer les
grains en fait on va prendre la tourbe
ici m 2 ici au fond la terrine ya il ya
une limite en fait donc rempli à la mi
temps avec eux la tour donc aussi je
vais prendre le tas ce que j'ai fabriqué
moi même c'est justement ce bois est un
petit une petite poignée voilà pas se
casser la tête
donc on va taxer le fond on va tâcher la
tourbe
voilà les germes entre ben je vais
prendre les rênes de marguerite donc ici
à les grains aujourd'hui on va semer les
graines harmonieusement sur sur toute la
surface et la terrine mais il ya
d'autres techniques de semis
donc ça sera l'objet d'une autre
émission voilà donc je vais commencer à
semer un
on a fermé les graines on touche plus là
donc ensuite après avoir fait cette
étape là on va apprendre le tamis et le
terreau semis terreau de semis
traditionnelle même on peut prendre 5
hétéro normale dont le tamis très
important si on met pas tu as mis la
terre sera trop compacte et la
germination ça sera rap en fait donc
voilà on va tamiser le terreau de semis
si voilà les res on écrase bien avec la
main un truc très important c'est de
noter sur l'étiquette la date et la
variété donc l'étape suivante maintenant
je vais prendre une plaque en métal
qu'alex va me passer
voilà en fait je vais pour la terrine
rompez à cette plaque d'eau et le
fermoir voilà donc on va laisser la
terrienne à l'intérieur et là tout va
aspirer l'eau on va pas fait d'arrosage
comme ça directement parce que l'eau
aura tendance à stagner
et ça ça va créer une pourriture des
graines ça commence à bien à bien
mouillé donc faudra bien surveiller
on va juste passer un petit coup de
barre pour une autre sur la surface afin
que la surface aussi et bien et bien
mouillé voilà on va faire ça
la dernière étape le vitrage en fait le
fait de mettre une vitre ici ça va crée
de la condensation
donc ça va chauffer les graines ça va ça
va donner une température idéale pour la
germination des graines et comme ça
aussi ici il ya un attaques d'insectes
ou ça ça va ça va déjà le protéger on va
reprendre l'ombrière pas très opaque
parce qu'il est trop noir folle et c'est
quand même un petit peu de lumière pas
beaucoup les plantes ont besoin humain
mais pas les graines les graines et sous
la terre donc ils ont plus besoin de
chaleur et de lumière en fait voilà donc
l'ombrière plus le vitrage ça va créer
la condensation qui va fait que les
graines vosgien roger amis voilà si on
suit bien la technique on aura un bon
roulement et au pire si site à site a
beaucoup plus bêtes jeu pourra partager
avec le voisin est comme ça tout au long
de l'année
now bonnes plantes et on va pouvoir
faire plaisir autour de nous voilà